hey guys nice to see you again Dave hey
Charlie
Candice good to meet you both hi thank
you for me out tonight I I host a
multi-disciplinary daily show in San
Francisco and something that is frequent
in conversation is nuance and the
importance of nuance in political
conversation and I think that you guys
all understand that and and do live that
and I just see a couple things happening
that I'd like to point out and then ask
a question about you know probably a
pretty good example is you know this the
signs that sorry the signs that say you
know socialism sucks you know there are
certain aspects of socialism like our
bridges and our police officers and
that's things that we pay for right now
together and that we appreciate maybe
there are other aspects of you know
immigration that are nuanced there's an
argument about h-1b visas there's an
argument about whether we should build a
wall or deport people so this is nuanced
conversation it's not binary right
binary is like science gravity exists
there's no post modernist discussion
about that gravity exists as binary
versus all these other topics are more
nuanced so my question is can we please
aim to be a little bit more nuanced how
can you be more nuanced and more Aquinas
more open-minded in our conversations
with people that may not hold the same
beliefs that we do in order to try and
build a better world together I will say
I think that's what tonight's showed
though I mean we were very nuanced we
said Sweden does got some good things
and Sweden does some bad things we said
America is not a perfect country but
it's the greatest country ever to exist
Dave and I had a nice we solved the
Americans immigration problem in five
minutes or less if some new ones so I
would say we are doing that but look I
would take one exception
you know roads and bridges are not
National Socialism that's local goods
and services that you pay for as a
utility so it's it's this idea that all
we live under that we have all these
wonderful things that are under
socialism is complete nonsense I'm Dave
I'll let you have some of that well the
only thing I would add to that and as
you know we've met a couple of times I
mean I think I've spent the last five
years of my life or so trying to find
some nuance and that's why I'm here and
that's why having these discussions is
so important and that's why I'll
continue having them it's really as
simple as that
one more one more you know my Big Finish
thank you there are certain aspects to
what youyou were discussing about you
know China's stealing our IP even though
that's true right shouldn't we also try
and collaborate with the north but dude
I'm not giving a five-hour lecture on
trade you have to be you have to give
you half the stock and some consider
being a little bit more quantum as' and
open-minded in your conversations with
other people that's all I have to say
thank you thank you I appreciate it all
right fair enough
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you